Justin Bieber and Selena Gomez jet out  of town you got a fetish for the 23 year  old singer and his ladylove were spotted  hopping on a private jet together in Los  Angeles on Saturday the two were seen  bundled up in warm attire for their  jaunt justin in light jeans a colorful  coat and tan sweatshirt while Selena  dressed in all black with an oversized  coat and boots  [Music]  the getaway comes after Justin and  Selena rekindled their romance back in  October  shortly after Selena and the weekend  called it quits the pair has been  spending plenty of time together since a  source tells ET Justin wants to be a  better man because he doesn't want to  screw things up with Selena  he knows he's lucky to have this second  chance and he's not taking it for  granted as I'm excited to go it's coming  [Music]  you